We could say you're trying
to teach your child to talk,
which of course you don't
do what you do to a child,
just talk to it.
But it's very interesting because there
have been studies of how parents talk to
children and what they do is always use
language that's slightly more complex
than the child can understand.
And they do it automatically.
It's part of our,
what a in some sense,
our innate knowledge
structure about language.
So you don't only use words
that the child understands,
use words that they understand plus
a few words and phrases and sentence
constructions that they don't.
And so that's sort of pulling them along.
And a Russian psychologist named the
Gods ski called that the zone of proximal
development and the zone of
proximal development is that place.
Cause it's a place in the environment
where information flow into the psyche is
maximized.
And that has to be.
So it has to be,
cause I comprehensible,
you know,
it's something I tried
to do in my lectures.
You know,
I tried to tell you things that you know
and associate them with things that you
don't know,
so that you're not swamped,
hopefully by an excess of
incomprehensible information,
but you don't think,
Oh God,
he's saying that again.
I already know that,
you know,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And uh,
anything that's dramatic
instructure is doing that for you.
It's keeping them,
it's keeping you on the edge of attention.
And that place is where your
adaptation is maximized.
Because not only are you firming up the
structure that's underneath your feet,
you're relying on it and you know,
it's,
it's part of the platform
on which you stand,
but you're absorbing information at a
rate that allows you to increase the
solidity and area of that solid ground
without undermining you so much that it
falls apart beneath you.
So it's lovely.
It's such a good idea because think
about what it would mean if it was true.
It would mean that if you pay attention
to what captures your interest and you
follow that,
that means you're going to always
be interested in what you're doing.
But even better than that,
it's going to mean that you're going to
maximize your adaptive capacity as much
as possible at exactly the same time,
man,
that'd be a great deal if it
actually happened to be true.
Now it's a bit complicated because
what culture wants from you and what is
intrinsically interesting to you,
there's going to be a conflict there,
right?
Because culture wants you to do what
a good cultural entity should do,
which is to do what you're told to do,
but you're not,
you know,
you're not a robot.
And so part of the existential problem
that you have in life is trying to figure
out some compromise between what you find
personally engaging and that develops
and supports you and what
the culture will provide,
uh,
resources to you for pursuing.
And it's hard.
There's no simple answer to it.
But I say that if you sacrifice your,
your capacity to engage in meaningful
activity to the security of a given
position and a dominance hierarchy,
then you turn into something
that's like a soul,
a slave.
And that's a really bad idea because
there's no way you can do that for any
length of time without
getting bored and resentful.
And once your board and resentful,
the move from that to dangerous is a very,
very small step.
So it's hard and it isn't even necessarily
the case that you're going to make
the balance.
You know you're going
to mail to manage it,
but if you don't,
you're going to pay a
massive price for it.
So I would say,
you know,
let,
don't let people mess around with what
you find compelling any more than is
absolutely necessary.
You know,
so because it's very dangerous to do that,
it's very dangerous to do that.
Just like it's dangerous not to find a
position in the dominance hierarchy at
all because then you end
up in a chaotic place.
And my experience being you,
you might wonder about this,
it's like what's the probability
that someone can live a healthy life,
healthy,
productive,
and stable life outside
of dominance hierarchy.
So without external structure.
And the answer to that is there might be
one person in this class that could do
that.
It's really hard because what happens to
most people is that if they don't have
a substantial amount of
external structure and routine,
they just fall apart.
They don't sleep properly,
they don't eat properly,
you know,
they're depressed.
It's tremendously effortful to continually
reinvent yourself day after day.
And so there's some real,
there's some real utility in
routine and social identity,
you know,
and young would say the part of you that
has adapted to re routine and social
identity is the persona and sort of the
mask you wear in public and might even
be who you think you are.
And he thought that people
who were only persona,
we're dangerous because they were only
thoughtless advocates of the system for
which they stood.
But he also believed that PR people
who had no persona where in an equally
terrible situation because
they're psychologically
chaotic and they don't have a
social structure around them to hem them
in and continually remind them how to
be sane and productive.
So it's a matter of balance.
You know,
there's,
there's horrors on both sides and
there's advantages on both sides.
And the trick is to place yourself in a
location where you're deriving maximum
advantage from both.
And you'll be able to tell if you do that.
Because if you are doing that,
you're going to find your life
engaging and meaningful enough.
So the fact that it's also tragic and
potentially composed at least partially of
slavery,
is going to be acceptable.
And that's what,
that's the goal in some sense.
It's a hard to do that,
but you know,
it's hard not to do it too.
So you're screwed either way.
So you might as well pick the path that's
going to be of maximum utility to you.